welcome back to true news youtubers talk
[__] again fake beef can you eat it
would recommend
[Music]
YouTube must be making more music videos
Lawrence oh no this one's a true story
[Music]
yeah
last week I was walking down the street
I was heading to the park I was passing
by a tree where some salty blood it's
rewear tie this Rakhi twist return to
ground another know why this has
happened it's really hard it's a true
story
I don't think so we're not watching the
video from a 2005 to 5 no this is so
you're trying to send me down the one I
miss about Malfoy Malfoy we'll put you
in the ground it's not much of a fighter
actually Malfoy no or Theo actually saw
finger the other day he's in good shape
nobody's not a fighter though he's a
good shooter at the ball right not a
fighter
Theo told me are they he did the walls
triple h's finisher perfectly head
degree did the pedigree just twice Joe
had to do Sweet Chin Music about 17
times cuz he wanted to get it just right
that's an exclusive piece of you only
get this on true news that was when I
was by the way playing golf with Theo
that's exactly how I feel right now
watching this what as if someone's
taking me away into a really dark place
yeah just dragging you down somewhere
deeper than hell yeah yeah I'm not gonna
turn around thinking a lost I'm coming
for your mouth boy I'm gonna get past
it's unusual in terms of lyrics I mean
we get the gist of what you know if the
video didn't exist I would definitely
have trouble keeping up with a narrative
like joella's funds at 2014 they've
grown up jaws growing up yeah it's time
for the content to grow up to this is a
throwback and if this is just a one-off
classic jaw silly video that we can
enjoy and laugh at real and cool yeah
but I don't want more of it I want I
want Joe to be making songs about what
it's like to be his age how he's feeling
went down to the club and I had a good
time so I put it in a little rhyme what
was going on in the club it was raucous
this girl was having a dance I wanted to
get in her presence right that's good so
you're trying to send
the one I miss about Malfoy Malfoy we'll
put you in the grow Malfoy I won't put
you in the ground muffle is literally
sitting in the back of the car being
kidnapped by what can only be described
as tall very mysterious really it's not
supposed to be a serious record do you
think but it's still bad can I just say
I'm just looking at something right now
yeah Khan has 1.1 million views on his
district
Joella 1.75 like we're talking about a
legend of YouTube he's going to the top
and he's never gonna stop but the cons
catching a bomb yeah that sort of Ryan
cotton is my camera mine after chatting
to the goons we settle on a match a
little 2v2 to get my friend back to v2
you've got them back already yeah yeah
we don't want to do this much anymore
okay we'll have him back then we got the
chemistry and straightaway Malfoy he's
got the skills a skills e this is just
bad I'm sorry Joe I love you but this I
can't sit here and criticize [__]
Randolph occasionally it was levels
ahead of this and then say this is good
I think it takes another level of skill
Zeus yeah another level of skills he's
to make a wrap this is this tweeze ease
this is another level of cringe I think
he's done this deliberately to lure us
in people go or boss Joe do it now next
video it's gonna be an in-depth
documentary you'll see oh come in to
finish up a job I scored a winner and we
crown the champion the finish up the job
a score the winner and we're crown the
chump beyond job and champions that's
the biggest stretch I've ever seen a
rough Mick come true but fair nice
[Music]
round that was actually really a good
warez way Steven snog express that hurt
it's made Steven tries troubled from
where's Hammond to Brighton how many
hours is that roughly about four or five
to do that Lane imagine Steven and jaw
making a diss track together how good
would that have been that would have
been great would have been amazing
that woulda been great ready this is cam
Kirk comes peace I'm looking forward
really is I thought we were watching his
music I'm looking forward to this I'm
into so [__] you enjoy yeah okay this is
great parity you all hooked Aussie I'd
love to have seen the behind-the-scenes
of him just standing next to the opening
of the sewer yeah get some that boys
back rich Oh CJ he's standing by the
sewer and why she's in a cat why is he
gonna swim cap are you what a stinker
your sight man come drink Seidman come
drink I said good that maybe that was
the best Lane we've seen in all the
distress I don't understand why are
entitled they're the thing that Sizemore
didn't drink okay that's actually you
can get that on Amazon now the sidemen
come drink like a little cup that's a
sideman come trigger dot shop cause you
tell you what kid - did y'all spend 10
minutes quite like Jesus in the manger
can I just say this is really good but
it's not really it is really good it is
really good
just as why is this good the the rhyming
is like rhyming is good right let's turn
the rhyming is good he's got some good
dishes an insult
finally though in accurate history Jesus
was a meek
child of him and crying in the manger I
don't like I don't like Jesus cameraman
to the point that if I actually ever see
Jesus cameraman I will happily punch him
in the face I don't like you
news flash like that Renee's dead she
doesn't
Rundle I gotta say YouTube cameraman he
is he's what he's the type of guy who if
I actually ever see him and if he
touches me in any way I will happily
give him a one bang in the face I often
say that I'll give you a one bang in the
face I swear I just I just pray I never
[__] see your [__] face in person
I swear I never see your [__] face in
person just to be absolutely clear I
just pray yeah dear Lord Jesus Christ
today we pray that Deji never has to see
Randall's face in person not honestly
can't and I swear this is the best
district yet could we like to be the new
boys to men yeah XO we could bring there
could be the poison with them yeah he
does look like a beaver he does isn't he
he's absolutely naked abuse that lion in
his distil with a London he's Barris
your beaver I'll never ever even try to
like you I'm never even gonna try and
like you like to be fair now if you if
you're it be this Christmas right you're
gonna spend a lot of time of your family
all right just keep you not like a
member of them don't say to them I hate
you I'm gonna go I'm gonna try and like
you grandma I'm not even gonna try and
like old hug yeah we all know that
happens when you hit your late twenties
[Music]
[__] got a type Jesus they're
all the same it's like he clued them
I've got to be honest looking at them
right now I think I know which one
you're most attracted oh yeah yeah I
think I know which one it's a tricky one
this cuz there's two that I think I know
you're gonna really like ready 1 2 3 -
oh you liked it whoa interesting she got
some titties owner I mean look at the
cleavage as well under faces gorgeous
that's bizarre pretty handsome guy yeah
I wouldn't call Caspar good-looking I
don't think he's good-looking fisher's
destroy people I think he's I think
claspers Norman ever looked at a woman
and went I like she's so determined and
she's really got a good career normal
ever thinks that ever ever you could
clean it test scores you could be a
solicitor we don't give a [__] don't
write women what they care about what
you do for a living they care about your
status and that youtubers benefit from
that as much as anyone you're saying he
would cuss or I've got this level of
woman without YouTube maybe for you but
everyone knows that it's up for the few
I think josh is funny
I like Josh I like Josh once again
though just put down the pen look we
need to let this go yeah and out for you
I'll be honest I feel like this was
written in crayon but before I go I need
to it's something number dare you
wearing the only jacket that looks like
hip-hop man but she can't go home we
live together bro my kid you know we
shake just for everybody's guys live
together like I know that this is fake
beef or whatever but like just even
joking that you [__] your mates
girlfriend isn't like that's not funny
yeah that's what I'm trying to say
that's this shit's not fun it's like
right we need to become relevant again
what we gonna do I don't know we're
going to a district [__] your girlfriend
you took a [__] in the toilet
let's go there's a lane just had guests
on the podcaster second [__] in the
toilet and we've never really worried
about it near me I mean Chris Eubank is
still getting over there he left the
country
yeah Kim a cop policeman to make up for
[Music]
the Casper replied but based on your
video I thought should be a treat know
how much more I can do there's tweets
that I see on Twitter where people go do
you know what I mean did you ever just
look at I just look at white people go
that was awful yeah it's weird because
when I started with Jill wellas video I
kind of was like yeah this is this is
button noise it's progressively gotten
worse
each time you know each video can I just
say she's got a [__] good off stock
girl alyssa is face bangs with her I
don't know can I just say admit shoutout
fair play well done well done
just one has to poop and we're trying to
get it out of everything
I'll get it out I'll just step on why
they tell all their friends this they
talk about everything
Jasmine needs to could I just say as
well hint of a camel toe so come on tell
what's good for getting a [__] out of a
girl you know the whole time they took
the sexy photo shoot one of them is Gus
but one of them literally they've
literally just gone can we have a big
[__] please and then they go great let's
have a let's have a shoot ironic you
know people people in the comments last
time asked me why do you care about this
I don't to be oh there you done I don't
give a [__] but really funny isn't it
someone who doesn't care you google it
an awful lot well not that the AUSA's
but the thing is it is just funny that
she's bothered about ELISA and Erica
there's the beef yeah it's called copper
[__] can we get there in a ring together
Erica versus ELISA I mean that would be
awesome water just like a broad bunnies
man no no no no you have to treat people
as equals now Brian come on well just
have some gloves on them to let them go
right what did you what what do I call
you I think I just usually easier ninja
okay I'll just clean as you say they're
probably not real ninjas around the
world going for the Shaolin monks are
just sitting there in a temple somewhere
watching this go on [__] [__]
ninja oh no like when they're messing
with me or troll with me sometimes if I
like if they want to get my attention
Jimmy Fallon and I think I do like Jimmy
is then sent by anything that anyone
ever says I think Jimmy Fallon I like
Jimmy a lot though one day I want to do
a project to the level where American
talk show hosts go show and tell us some
stories as long as we can eyes
[Applause]
I can't play a little game I'll Jamie I
love it I don't want to do that so much
fun you get to chat Jimmy Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Kimmel they're all go Jimmy you
have over 20 million subscribers on
YouTube
this year alone you've streamed for
three thousand four hundred hours
that's 142 days worth of gaming wow
that's a lot of stuff everyone give him
a round of applause he sits on a chair
and plays a game ladies and gentlemen
come on look at what you're doing huh oh
and what do you do yeah what do you
think of the parents that don't want
their kids playing for tonight and it's
a big controversy there dude yeah no
it's it's simple are they doing well in
school are they doing well in their
everyday activities and if they are then
reward them and if they're not you know
it's it's a great motivational you know
tool he needs to be our spokesperson
eating supporters right foot forward
yeah and he's doing a good job he's
saying all the right things he's the
Anthony Joshua of gaming right now he's
just saying everything perfect yeah I
want to talk about New Year's Eve you're
doing a big deal explain every what's
happening 4:00 p.m. New Year's Eve
you're gonna be in Times Square
yes it's uh you know not too far from
here I'll be streaming inside luckily
tomorrow I be free yeah yeah it's cuz it
gets really cold and it's gonna be
overlooking Times Square it's gonna be
amazing twelve hour stream with a bunch
of special guests friends thinks I want
to celebrate New Year's Eve by going and
watching someone play for tonight things
have changed
when I was young it was how many losses
could you neck on within the
neighborhood yeah now it's how many
kills can you get in 20 seconds I would
make over ten every New Year's really
easy we were you then standing in the
dance clubs going yeah yeah
[Music]
it's so funny but why would you want to
watch you know the the best of the best
play you know football soccer you know
hockey you know it's just it's
entertainment right so you watch you
know the NFL and things like that
because you want to watch people do
things that you know you can it's kind
of the same thing with gaming and
streaming if I wanted to all of a sudden
compete in the UFC I have to go and have
amateur fights I have to learn all the
skills thousands and thousands of hours
of rolling around to get me black belt
in Brazilian jiu-jitsu and to manage to
master the art of kickboxing and then
get in the cage
win a lota fight and then compete for
the title and have thousands of people
want to see me do that if I want to play
fortnight all right here we go then it's
a bit different it's a bit you cannot
you can't compare me playing fortnight
and streaming to being in the UFC or the
Premier League it is so different it
isn't the same as that under somebody
saying the jump he's made there is a
huge jump that isn't isn't a real
logical there's not a reality it's not
isn't real ok so this is a weird one in
this video count how many times he says
the words Slovenia I think I'm about to
book a flight to Slovenia in Slovenia in
a town called we are going to Slovenia
object booked us a flight today's a day
let's go to Slovenia deep
Sokol bro
we're in Slovenia it's so good these
laws custard the [__] out of this this
is very similar you're editing isms yeah
except I don't Lee I don't say sube you
so much.you romanticizes it quite a lot
but I don't blame him he should do it I
mean he's doing some intense [__] yeah
boy this guy's in Slovenia he's he's
he's just sitting showing on a chimney
oh my god that's so [__] crazy that's
great I don't even oh my god what if he
fell down into her
meanwhile Deji sitting at home you you
you you you you you you you I pray you
want to pray for night skin yeah but not
for Randolph [__] hell Randolph's not
up at our haunt Hubbell think that one
days when a [__] die though yeah what
a legacy he's gonna leap when people
warned him one day you're gonna die he
felt it was certain death yeah he's done
a lot of great videos like this we've
you've beat up a lot of things we've
seen a lot of views being there done
that got the tape
start tunneling yeah don't risk your
life anymore you've done it now
you've done a great job he's done enough
[Music]
that's Macaulay Culkin he really is
though isn't he literally as though he
did a lot of drugs he went on a bit of a
bender but session right okay sessions
okay I'll remind you imagine how good
home alone would be now if he had like
Google and Siri all of you just a grown
man who could fight them yeah yeah
literally bigger than sticky bandits
[Applause]
hey Google begin operation Kevin
operation Kevin underway this really any
operation Brian yeah be like huge
projector screen drop stone porn or
right and the robbers the wrong
everything the moisturizer arrives at
the right hand side right issues at the
left right goodnight
and you don't care that the robbers are
taking everything you're just wanking
away the minute that the other you think
robbers somehow has some sort of level
oh they've got morals right
what is it don't look at a man
masturbating yeah right I know if I was
gonna burgle someone and someone just
came up with a dick in the end you'd run
away wouldn't you yeah
get back mister rabbika back especially
me yes react to this [__] for me alright
this is a robot that can jump just like
in any way you would program it to you
so it jumps off and then it look that
looks real that looks like a real human
what the [__] that is so [__] weird
how cool is that though look at this
look it swings its limbs yes this is
painful tell me is this that painful
well how do you put yourself through
that that looks awful [__] hole yeah
no it's bad isn't it this is just a
little bit of history I'm gonna I'm
gonna go and prepare the lunch you just
stay here yeah I like a hair like that
oh my god it's she's just bloody lovely
as in Shermans the thongs gonna come
into fashion that's what I'm wondering
[__] hell got me bloody blood
pressure up here yeah they're just not
showing the thongs unfortunately they're
not they're not showing it they showed
everything from behind until she got in
thongs and I what and Hanaka place
alright that's when you see just how
wide her hips are big ass okay so what
are we looking at horse-racing
I love horse racing it's confirming the
ground is now goodbye beautiful lady
it's a man actually directly you could
have just caught on and not certainly
it's also the guests that go there guess
that goes
these are Disney Princesses or Disney
female heroines have been turned into
almost real-life drawings okay I'm
wondering which you find the most
attractive
okay I don't think any of them are if
they're drawings no no but that that
looks like real a are these secretly you
know what rock covers no no no these are
literally just these are just madness
all right okay
DUI area I've always liked the real why
I mean redheads are a good good
July Pocahontas yep oh she's definitely
your type Snow White is your type mirror
mirror on the wall who's the [__] of
them all is Brian it's Brian
I show no nice Oh Thelma I've always
liked geeks okay I love geeky girl I
think I know who your favorite is and I
think it is snow white because Snow
White is girl-next-door who Arizona it's
pure girl next door and for you you
think she's a little bit chubby and you
like that not she is actually a little
bit chubby right thank you knows me yeah
Normie I know Brian very well you would
you ever no no no they're cartoons mates
that's disgust to be honest with you it
was a [__] show but hopefully you
forgive us for this yeah that was good
five minutes thanks for coming we've got
quality I mean sort of it was a another
[__] show in a couple of years the
Christmas podcast Christmas day that
we'll be out on the main channel
featuring will any Steven tries Chuck
mate and I'm a life brilliant Romano's
too
we get if we weren't in it we get to
steamin to be honest with you to the
point where some youtubers in that group
had a thrall afterwards we let you be
the judge of that
when you watch the podcast enjoy it we
spoil you pricks love us subscribe to us
like the video comment all that good
Merry Christmas and a merry merry
Christmas